I watched the menu I wish you were in
the menu got chopped up I would be the
s'mores I would happily die as s'mores
which part would you be the Crusty
little cracker
wait no one you guys weren't obsessed
with Iron Chef I liked Iron Chef I like
there's a there's a Iron Giant
I do love yeah it's so scary the fact
that you guys scary it's sad it made me
cry so sentimental that is scary when
you're a small person every movie is sad
though every movie when you're little as
had everyone's parents die yeah why do
they do that it's really [__] up are
they preparing us yes
for the age we're at but an Iron Chef
they would introduce a certain
ingredient which would be a surprise to
the competing chefs so like for example
you know and then it would be some like
guy announcing the ingredient that they
would have to incorporate into their
dishes it would be like pizza dough and
it would be like that's how that's how
he said it he would announce it like
that and it was so exciting it was like
most of my 20s was just like Iron Chef
and what did they make with pizza dough
no you're not allowed to do it she's
half asian yeah it's a Japanese guy
I just thought it was like
foreign
by betterhelp find more balance with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com trash
Tuesday today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday hi slugs I am back on the road
with my stand up and I cannot wait to
see you guys June 3rd I'll be in Atlanta
that's so soon June 4th in Raleigh and
then I'm coming to New York City DC
Boston Madison Chicago and Detroit get
tickets at Esther onice.com yo what up
I'm back I'm here I'm very excited to be
on the road performing comedy doing fun
meet and greets with you guys and
selling new merch you can come see me
I'm a goobies in Baltimore June 2nd and
June 3rd I'm going to be in Salt Lake
City Utah at Wise Guys comedy club with
Josh Potter June 9th and 10th I'm going
to be in San Antonio Texas June 23rd and
24th in August I'll be in Philadelphia
at the punchline the 11th and 12th I'm
going to be at the Calgary Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival with Andrew
Schultz August 27th I'm going to be in
Austin Texas at the Vulcan gas company
October 6th and 7th I also have a lot of
dates going up in San Francisco San Jose
and a lot of other very cool places so
go to annieleterman.com shows for that
and every Thursday you can come hang out
with me and Todd and any crazy guest
that we pick up at anniewood that's
every Thursday at 9am PST we go live
doing a live chat so come hang out with
us on YouTube see you there
[Music]
thank you
you guys I terrorized my clitoris on
Monday
I'm not well I I just can't touch it for
I think I I'm Banning myself for
masturbating for do you ever have it to
where it's like all of a sudden you're
like oh my God my pussy's like raw like
this is my clits like my whole I'm like
this is like it's in a different I
repositioned it I wrote I'm Raw I don't
know what the [__] some I don't know
what happened but
um I'm out the game for the next two
weeks I too hard on myself what are you
too often are you gonna be able to not
do it yeah yeah no no I have good
self-control wait so you had it was
FaceTime sex the first one was FaceTime
sex with a very cute boy and sister I
heard that you [__] a fan
I heard that I also want to let you know
I'm a fan
there was one lucky contestant out there
there might have been yeah which I just
want to say props Esther have you ever
done that had a fan
well it's like guys have sex with their
fans so and it's so different so when a
girl does it I'm like this I want to
shatter from the rooftops I think that
rules I I will say that it exceeded All
my expectations yeah the sex was great
the makeout was great he was hot he was
like really caring and doting he's like
literally perfect oh my God so one
lesson a ticket buyer he pays for
tickets
I'm like and you pay full price there's
no guess list so you didn't know when
you buy a ticket you don't know what
that could lead to oh God Esther what
are you setting us up for oh yeah we
happened yeah well no that's not how we
met the world we met in a more casual
way it was so not casual any don't even
give any more information don't get more
information oh you cannot participate in
this conversation I don't know I don't
know what she's talking or band but how
like because usually you're like okay
this is a bad idea
but it wasn't you guys
it was not a tiny but not a freaking
morsel of regret in me wow and she's
getting off and I'm still horny for him
to be on the level two where you can do
FaceTime sex like you know like that's
like a wait isn't that like a almost
like a higher tier of intimacy to be
willing to do FaceTime sex I believe
knowing that they're screen recording it
no I'm posting it on oh my God no wait
can I I'm gonna ask what do you think
about that dude because I have straight
up put the lens right into my [__]
[__] hole like it was grotesque I know
like I was things were spread open lips
were pulled apart [__] were exposed
how many holes
that's just got some more directing to
do pull the lip a little further this
way now I'm gonna ask a prying question
yeah you don't have to answer was this
fan the one that sent a letter to your
merch person or whatever oh God no
remember when she was like I love this I
was like kalila the hope you're giving
to the letter writer there was a person
who sent
um a love letter to our merch people
it was like can you please like let
kalila know that you know but they sent
into the merch guy like the person who
does all like our orders and stuff and I
read it and it was really sweet but also
know that though
you just sent a picture of her [__]
back with the lips
she's like there's a little much wait is
this I mean like is is this like what do
you call it when you um [__] someone in
the workplace like oh
um
fraternization but the opposite of that
but like is this illegal what I'm doing
he's my age
there's no illegal it's not illegal
right is it like a struggle no because
he obviously already like likes me so
I'm I it's maybe a disadvantageous for
him wait can we talk about I'm wearing
the same shirt I was wearing on the
[__] up now I want to talk about how
I think it requires a more intimate
wouldn't it be a little bit like higher
tier of intimacy to have FaceTime sex
with Todd yes but wouldn't it be a
higher intimacy if I was wearing a
different shirt you guys talk to each
other
yeah smell it wait so you're you're
saying you fraternized with someone that
had a prior Association
yeah am I taking advantage of a
situation no because men have sex with
their fans every night after shows and
you oh it's like and then I have the
higher level of power I think
yeah and I bought I did
my thing is like I'm coming in already
knowing he likes me that's there's
nothing law to do with that no nothing
you didn't I think I mean I'm not Ben
Franklin but I feel like you're good
thank God
thank God then I'm not then I'm not
ashamed to say it I [__] a fan
he had more than just that everything oh
my God our guest is here she's here so
enough about us our guest has joined us
welcome Amanda Knox hello or is the
headlines caller foxy knocking
uh I mean it's just so sad how it got
appropriated because I got that nickname
from my soccer teammate so it was like a
girls thing yeah and then it became no
no no no thank God no no my coach was
great he was like a military just crazy
guy who ran us until we threw up but he
never ever did any thing weird and sexy
at us which is fantastic I know I'm so
grateful for those two to three teachers
the ones that actually like did their
job yeah well you know you're right
because I had a friend
um who dated the high school soccer
coach and she was 15 and he was in
history he was hot they're they're
always hot yeah they're always really
hot they're always hot and they always
run with you but yeah and you kind of
like it how they boss you around you
know my swim coaches were all punish you
a little bit I know which is why are
they coaching Us in Speedos why are they
some coaches are never hot
they're never hot mine is from the
soccer coaches yes
he I loved my swimming coach his name
was Joe Jackson I know that sounds like
it was a different joke
his name was also Joe Jackson and he
wore these like rainbow suspenders and
he always had like a lollipop and uh
like a bucket he was raving he was all
the time
always on Molly his ecstasy back up but
he died he had like a heart attack while
he was driving and his daughter
quit swimming
that's why no
great beautiful story well I'm trying to
lead us into a little trial you know
what I mean
before you got here we were deliberating
on whether or not it was okay that I
recently had um sex with a fan
oh that's interesting so I just got out
of a 10-year relationship and my last
sexual encounter was with someone who
was initially a fan which grew into a
friendship which then grew into that
which then became my my lover basically
wait have you had sex with yeah did you
get
people to [__] you while you're in
prison
um uh yeah no there were a lot of people
who sent me some really weird [__] and
when I was in prison so like either they
had photoshopped my head onto like some
naked woman you were the OG uh AI porn I
mean oh my God there's I mean I'm not
the OG I'm sure lots of other women were
before me but yeah no I got plenty of
people who like straight up photoshopped
and printed it out because that's how
you had to send it to me and then wanted
me to sign it and send it back to them I
also had people send me things like
underwear and bras that they wanted me
to sign and send back to them really
people just asking me for my underwear
so what do you think people it's just
like you were pretty and they had like a
fetish for someone accused of murder
um I think I think the whole I think a
fetish is a little bit of actually no I
want to remove the word fetish because
like it's a bad word like it's I think
people's fetishes are their own business
and they're totally fine but like I do
think that like fantasy played a big
part in how I was particularly vilified
and I feel like the way that like to
give you an example one of the ways that
like very early on the detectives who
were investigating the case like they
were asked in these interviews it's like
this big all of a sudden this big case
and they had just arrested me and they
were like how did you know it was this
girl next door and they were like she
smelled like sex
and it was like wow okay so first of all
when were you ever near me enough like
to to get a whiff first of all and
second of all like I think you're
projecting maybe just a little bit
um so I feel like a lot of it came down
to like them getting strong Vibes about
me very early on and they didn't know
where to attribute them and I I get I
get some I have some stroke feelings
that like potentially what was happening
was there was some fantasy projection in
a tragic context and that just got all
mixed up yeah was any part of you like
oh I didn't realize I was pretty
um I again like it's it all feels super
[__] fake to me like I feel like the
the image of me of being this like
hypersexualized person was not even
accurate I feel like the entire thing
was so incredibly exaggerated that it
never I never actually felt like anyone
was really talking about me right they
were talking about an idea of a person
that had nothing to do with me that just
happened to have my face and my name
and so like no I was never flattered
wait that is that is wild Ester you had
some jealousies right well I was just
wondering like what would you say what
would you say to someone like was there
any excitement of like being so famous
so fast and like also in the context of
being pretty wait that's what you were
jealous at that time no I've just okay
after like your case I would sort of
like in my head make jokes about like
how I thought that
like the only way I could ever be really
famous like and be beautiful as if I was
accused of murder and
now
but you know you didn't need to be
because Eileen warnos they did a whole
movie about her who's that a monster
would they had Charlize there and play
her but in real life she
how could you not know Monster no I know
Monster but I guess I don't know like
energy drink I'm gonna switch the
subject
um back to your question
about getting famous really fast was
there any did you feel any sort of like
little I am literally like headline news
in the world holy [__]
um
can I ask how old you are you don't want
to know I don't want to know I'm 35. oh
you're 35. yeah [__] okay we're the same
age that's why it's like we were the
same age at this time that this happened
and like
uh so how old were you when this
happened I was 20. okay so I was also 20
so young and barely a person
life and then you were gonna be in there
forever so they were asking for life
imprisonment and I ended up getting
sentenced to 26 years oh holy [__] and
you're just like what the [__] yes
exactly yeah you're like are you [__]
kidding me yeah so to answer your
question and then so we can get back to
your question right because you have
you're dealing with a a potential
ethical crisis to get back to your
question
um Fame was not anything that I was
remotely thinking about at the time I
was like stuck in a prison cell
even fully like aware to ask the the
like lame questions
she's representing Kenzie for us that's
why I asked the question because like
actually one I remember when I first
came home from prison like I'm super
just like couldn't believe it yeah super
traumatized and like and this is when I
actually was first sort of introduced to
the fact that like this was such a huge
thing like I my family had been saying
like this thing has gotten really out of
control and they would tell me about it
but of course I'm in a prison cell where
I only have access to so much
information and so I don't like my my
access to this is every time I walk into
a courtroom there's hundreds of people
there who are taking pictures and like
yelling things at me but I've never been
in a courtroom before so I don't know
what's [__] normal I think that might
be nice I don't know and so my family's
telling me this thing is out of control
I don't really fully comprehend this
until I get home and there's a press
conference waiting for me at the airport
yeah and how many years after this is
four years it's so in prison crazy and
then so I get home I'm coming out of the
airplane first of all even getting out
of Italy was high-speed car chases from
Paparazzi who are ramming our car oh my
God
Esther is still jealous
I was just like when does it get bad but
like the my weird moment of like Oh
weird people actually know about me was
when the local records store at like
this local record store where I used to
buy like CDs when I was a kid on their
like outdoor sign instead of being like
you know Macklemore playing it was
welcome home Amanda oh and I was like
oh my God and then I was like oh my God
people know about me and I was like oh
no
people like like this is They Don't Know
About Me is the problem because again it
wasn't the story was never about me like
they they made it about this idea of a
person who didn't exist the whole the
guy who actually committed this crime
nobody's ever heard of him because
and and so here I am in a world that
thinks it knows who I am
and so to get back to your point one of
the first things that I did was one of
my um teachers brought me into my high
school to talk to her class
just be like hey you know you've been
through this crazy experience do you
want to like share some wisdom or
whatever answer some kids questions and
I remember being utterly heartbroken
when the first thing that a kid asked
was what is it like to be famous and I
was like I'm not she's like how old are
you because you act like you're a second
grader
no and I but like it that's I think
that's something that we don't really
fully understand is that when there's a
person in front of us that's in in this
like big way we sort of assume that the
bigness of it is a part of it and it's
like no I'm just a little person living
in this huge overwhelming experience and
it's come to Define my life in ways that
I have no control over right and
[__] me now what yeah so to get back to
your question how do you I mean I don't
know what what's your uh
what does it mean that he's a fan what
does it like how well it's somebody
who's listened to my podcast for the
last eight years right so come to love
you through your work correct that's a
way parallel which is strange because a
lot of the stories that I tell I are
hyperbole like they're exaggerations of
my life they're not necessarily like the
accuracy is not there like right um
heightened material it's a way how are
you telling it's storytelling it's
podcasting it's exaggerated
um like for instance when I say like you
know like I was molested as a child or I
was um inappropriately touched by my
doctor but instead of saying that I'll
say I was fisted by my family doctor
right hyperbole right um but he has
gotten to know me and gotten to like me
through that and when we finally met it
almost felt like there was some type of
like power dynamic because here was a
stranger in front of me and he knows
everything and he knows everything about
you
ask me
yes
role play doctor does not sound hot to
me at all well especially when she's
molesting yeah and I had my own personal
Larry Nazar like I'm so sorry because
you've got too much business to get to
when you go to the doctor
tell you what's going to get me out of
all my work tell me
again
to friends and now it doesn't feel like
there is a power Dynamic like I really
genuinely respect and like this person
and I feel like he genuinely respects
and likes you for you for me now because
I've definitely had the experience of
feeling like somebody who I thought I
had a special connection with I realized
later on had an idea of me that was
based upon this whole crazy story and
like at one point he told me that he
thought I was The Reincarnation of Joan
of Arc oh
and I was like you know right right the
burning
um You probably have to live up to that
that's the thing yeah it's like you if
you are an idealized version of a person
then you'll never be able to be the
person that they want you to be nor the
person you need to be so like that's my
concern is it's like do I want you to be
someone that's their idea of a person or
are they genuinely curious about who you
are and are willing to accept you for
right I think for this person I think he
was
um
um genuinely surprised and happy that
um I was
right it wasn't like fully fisted that I
was just a pretty normal normal you know
I think it started to grow and he
realized that I was really just kind of
this small thing right
um and the person yeah and um all your
glory that's when we really bonded it is
crazy and you're like really reminding
me of this concept like everyone is just
a person like Brad Pitt is just a person
just no Brad was a theater major
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp I
will say that it is very easy to get
caught up in what everyone else in your
life needs really Esther
I just want to take that line and never
and never take a moment to think about
what you need from yourself okay therapy
has helped me figure out how to actually
love myself because you think you love
yourself you don't you need to it takes
work and without a therapist and without
help guiding me to get there it was it
was never going to happen for me and if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule you guys therapy
has been an indispensable part of my
life it is the reason I'm alive today
and I recommend it to anybody even if
you are doing well I always say just
keep your grass green you'll be
surprised little things your head's
telling you to be honest it does suck
that like we live in a culture where we
do all need therapy and that just is
what it is and better help is such a
great option for that because it's the
easiest most convenient version and you
can do it from home so there's really it
takes the excuses out of it yeah it's a
good starter therapy too like if you've
never gone to therapy before and you
want to do something that's not going to
be like
give you a panic attack this is a great
option and it they have this option
where you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge they have
this really great Journal feature and
all you really need to do is fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist like I said anytime for no
additional charge
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday
how many times have you been baited into
we'll try it for 30 days just enough
time to try it doesn't completely forget
to cancel it and now you it's three
years now you're the only one with the
blue check mark the only one that paid
for your Twitter checkmark
I was a chosen one it was just me and
Stephen King that Milan felt we deserve
to be verified
um I'll tell you this rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place over
80 percent of people have subscription
that they forgot about and chances are
you're one of them and like you know the
Stars app or what whatever weird thing
where you just wanted to watch one show
and then completely forgot about it I
have about six of those on my iPad right
now use rocket money to help you figure
that out also rocket money helps you
manage all of your finances in one place
and automatically categorizes your
expenses so you can easily track your
budget in real time and also get alerted
if anything looks off
over 3 million people have used rocket
money saving the average person listen
to this 720 a year that is so much you
guys oh my God that's a pair of
sunglasses but any just one I'm just
kidding I'm done overspending a lot of
money saved yay rocket money will
quickly and easily find your
subscriptions for you and for any you
don't want to pay any more just hit
cancel and Rocket money will cancel it
for you it's that easy it does suck
though because it does take to the end
of the cycle so your blue check mark
does show up but it gets it does get it
for you stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday
[Music]
I have heard I'm not sure if I've heard
this set about you or if it's something
that you said
or if I'm somehow just like making it up
but I feel like I've heard about you
that you feel like you cannot be the
silly person that you truly are because
like this very serious thing happened to
you and like maybe you have to like hold
back on being silly out of like respect
or something is that real yeah so that's
something that I've been slowly
processing and grappling with over the
past freaking 15 years of my life
because going into this whole experience
I you know one of the ways that I was
vilified is when people called me like
quirky and their way of saying like oh
she's quirky turned into quirky is also
capable of murder right like quirky
means that she's abnormal quirky means
that she's depraved and so there was
this like weird which is crazy because
quirky to me I'm like I think of Zooey
Deschanel on New Girl right well
applicable yeah and it was it was a
stretch and it was always a stretch
which is why it felt like there was no
way that anyone would ever believe it
and like going into like the day to
receive my verdict I thought it was all
gonna like the adults in the room would
be like okay so we're done like with
this like charade of nonsense let's like
let the poor girl go home and then when
they were like 26 years in prison I was
like oh oh were you like blacked out at
that point that must have been so did
you go in kind of knowing how the
verdict was gonna go or where you're
like get I'm I'm getting the [__] out of
home
I was 100 100
convinced I was going home so in that
moment when you hear guilty what what's
happening
um so what it felt like
um was like the ground fell out from
beneath me and then fell on top of me
um and then I had this like tremendous
existential crisis of everything I
thought I could count on the world no
longer of course it's true yeah um the
truth doesn't even matter anymore oof
and
um now this is my life yeah and so
um
what was your question before that
though like you're a silly person that
maybe cannot is you don't feel allowed
to be silly because right so yeah I mean
I love comedy I love um I'm a silly
person I was a theater you would have
bullied the [__] out of me
um and
um and I just love like I'm a I'm a
quirky kid who likes to have fun I play
Dungeons and Dragons I go to Ren Fair
like I'm I'm a fun like that kind of
person and
um I'm a silly kind of person but
because so many people have come to know
me through the context of like an utter
[__] tragedy and like a horrible
brutal tragedy
they think that if I am being silly it
isn't somehow it's somehow a commentary
upon this tragic horrible brutal thing
that happened to my friend and they're
unable to like distinguish and so like
for example one of the ways that I deal
with like how everything everything I
went through is sometimes I make jokes
about it I joke about being in prison I
joke about being wrongly accused and
then people are like how dare you make
jokes because your friend was murdered
and I'm like I didn't make a joke about
my friend being murdered I didn't you're
used also that's literally like a theme
of this show as we all use laughter to
cope with hard things like I always talk
about like the hardest I've ever laughed
is at my grandfather's funeral like we
just like they talk about being molested
I'm like he like laughter and humor is
how I cope how all this cope so it's
like I hear you say that and I'm like
duh of course but people don't
understand but also it's like they're
not even like taking into account that
like your friend like how traumatizing
it is if you're not even like involved
the two things happen your friend died
and then you're acknowledging that a lot
of people forget to like yeah yeah I
before I was ever like a victim of the
Criminal Justice System I was an
indirect victim of murder right if I had
been home that night I would have been
right like so I think people forget that
then like it was just by luck and being
but I met a guy and was hanging out with
him the night that somebody broke into
my house and murdered my roommate yeah
so [__] and like just being falsely
accused of any tiny thing I'm like it's
the most infuriating much less like a
man's crime my roommate was raped and
murdered and they were like oh you know
she must have orchestrated a sex game
and it's like are you kidding me well I
am I'm very relaxed to like men's Brains
well it's that fantasy thing yeah such a
fantasy always I have like I've been
your [__] boners you asked about I've
been pretty open about how I I really I
I used to watch True Crime and I won't
watch it anymore because I don't like
the like
like basically what you're saying like I
was watching an episode of Dateline and
I was it was one of my friend's sisters
and the minute it became like a real
thing which you don't get that Grace
from people because they feel entitled
to it and they don't understand that
there's a real person behind it and that
with like
you know it's not to say that they
aren't stories worth telling it's just
it's just that like so often the people
who are telling those stories are not
the people who are actually the ones
with the most invested who have the most
at stake right in fact I don't know do
you guys know that I have a podcast yes
okay well what's it called it's called
Labyrinth and then the most recent like
mini series we have is is called blood
money and it's all about this it's all
about like the history of True Crime and
the problems with its ethics and like
all these open questions because it's
not just this easy black and white yeah
of course so because also you want like
the story to be told you want but it's
there is something about like I'm like
eating popcorn watching this and like
it's just no I just want popcorn that's
just like I'm jealous of the popcorn
um you bring up like oh wow actually
like no one points out that your friend
was murdered and like the feeling like
that could have been you if you were
home or whatever like what before the
craziness of being a falsely accused of
a crime like what is that even like to
come home did you discover that like are
you are you screaming are you like that
must have been its own surreal
experience so yeah
um thank you for asking that so there
was
um from the discovery that my roommate
had been murdered to my arrest was five
days
and I was the one who came home and
discovered that my house had been broken
into however I never saw her body
because somehow I don't know actually
why or how this happened but her door
the door to her bedroom was locked and
she was murdered in her bedroom I think
what happened is the murderer had been
rifling through her things to get money
or credit cards or whatever and had
grabbed her key and like locked her door
so here I am I come home I notice that
my front door is wide open I noticed
that there's like I eventually I sort of
poke around and I discover that there's
a window broken and I'm like oh my God
someone broke into our house and then I
start calling my roommates I have three
roommates
only one of them answers the phone two
of them do not and so the one that does
answer the phone says oh my gosh okay
you need to call the cops and I'm like I
don't even know how to call the cops in
Italy yeah so I get Rafael and my
boyfriend to call the cops for me they
come they arrive my other roommate
arrives but you already had an Italian
boyfriend
she's jealous again okay sorry keep
going um yeah again like I started
Freaky Friday oh my God you're so lucky
I actually do feel like I'm the luckiest
person in the world because I'm not dead
right now yeah
um and other people in my position have
spent way longer in prison than I have
so if you think about it I'm actually
quite lucky
um yeah so I because not I caught you
know I called all the people to figure
out what was going on the police arrived
my roommate arrived and they broke down
Meredith's door and discovered her body
and I I did not see into her room I did
not see what happened to her all I heard
or all that happened was suddenly a
bunch of Italian people were screaming
and yelling and talking very quickly in
Italian and I was not fluent at that
point so I was very confused about what
was going on and so we were rushed out
of our house and then I was taken to the
police station and I was asked to answer
questions
and I ended up being questioned for 53
hours holy [__]
um and uh and slowly over the course of
being questioned and talking to people
in the um in the police office I
discovered what had happened
so Jesus Christ and then
um do you feel like so how did you meet
Chris how'd you meet your husband oh we
have actually a really cute story it's
not a Tinder story yes although those
can be cute too I guess yeah um no so I
was at the time that I met my husband
um he was writing novels you know being
a poetry itinerant artist guy and I was
living in hiding writing like Arts
correspondence for a local newspaper
under a pseudonym and so I would like go
to plays and write reviews or I would
like read Advanced copies of novels and
I was given an advanced copy of his
novel so I like to say that I wasn't
sleeping with him until after I read it
um anyways called War of the
encyclopedists and
um is there anything like more like cute
than you read his book like I read his
book and then at the very next day after
I like submitted my review to the paper
I walked out of my apartment and in like
this Diner window across the street was
like a a sort of
poster like you would see for like a
music show but it was for a book reading
for his welcome home Amanda no no
um and it was at my local bookstore and
I was like you know what [__] it like I
never go out in public I never do
anything I never go out I'm just gonna
go and check out this book reading so I
went and it was there that I met him and
of course people are like whisper
whisper whisper I'm in an oxygen and
Knox is here and I'm just like so I'm
sitting there trying to be invisible
failing epically he's up there doing his
like I'm a cool like book guy and I and
and and then at the end of it I asked
him for to for an interview for the
paper and like what was so nice about
Chris is like he had his nose in books
the entire time that I was going through
my experience he he like knew of me he
wasn't he knew that my name was a name
that people knew but he's not like a
true crime guy so he didn't like know
yeah and he didn't bother to Google me
when he met me so like the first nine
months of our friendship was just like
hanging out and being a normal person
and then of course people are always
asking him like what do you think what
do you think and and he's like dude
she's just my friend like oh that's you
know sweet and then he murdered that
book
he writes romance novels you don't know
wait a second so you wrote Under a
pseudonym was there ever a part of you
when you finally did come home was there
ever a thought like I should change my
name look completely different abandon
this image that these people had created
of Me by being somebody else completely
and living that life with a little bit
more freedom so I here's the thing I
knew that that was a trap and that
wasn't actually freedom because one the
stubborn part of me was like there's
nothing wrong with Amanda Knox I didn't
do anything right wrong so I don't have
to be the one that changes my name and
like tries to hide my identity I love
that the other thing was whether or not
other people knew who I was or what my
experience was I knew right and so if I
sort of like tried to live a life where
I pretended like that didn't happen I
knew that that was ultimately only going
to make my make me feel distant from
everyone in the world around me so
what's so inspiring that's just I mean
because like I think just like even just
by virtue of being in a podcast or like
you know being up for consumption for
the last decade there is always that
feeling in me where I just want to like
cower and run and hide if anyone has any
like criticisms about me so I really
love what you're saying it's like look
like I just am who I am right like
there's no running away from that you
know you didn't do anything wrong and
that is that is the most important thing
yeah and it's a it's a thing that
happened to me and so like if I'm
navigating the world as if prison didn't
happen to me like I'm one lying to
myself and then I'm lying to everybody
else and that doesn't make for a good
foundation for any kind of actual
intimate relief is it hard to talk about
does it like bring you to a place or
um depends on different
Parts
um I've I've taken the um the stance
that there's no wrong questions and
there's nothing that's off the table
just even for me like
like I shouldn't feel like anything is
too I don't want to be afraid of
anything that I've experienced so I'm
open to talking about anything and all
of it that said there are like moments
when it's like this is not an
appropriate time for you to be asking me
about the worst experience of my life
when I'm trying to pay for my groceries
at the grocery store oh [__] like that
kind of thing is it's like no thank you
I didn't I want to sign up for this I
want to gossip with you but you're the
gospel yes you're like but you're
wanting us up with me you don't want it
people will like I've had somebody like
holding my credit card be like so did
you really do cartwheels and I'm like so
and then do you keep do you touch are
you in in touch with anyone from that
time of your life like I'm in touch with
Rafael who is the Italian boyfriend
you're so jealous of that
um yeah no um he's he's doing okay
um I think he's had a worse time trying
to
reintegrate back into life one because
he's in Italy in this in the stigma of
the accusation is much bigger there
um and I don't know I feel like I'm
really again lucky because I um I don't
I have anger but that's not the Primary
Emotion that I feel about everything I
feel more sad and so I think sadness is
a is an emotion that allows me to
actually reach out and ask for help and
ask for connection whereas anger is
something that is very very isolating
and I think that Raphael is still
grappling with a lot more anger
um justifiably did he go to prison too
he was in prison for four years long
exactly wow because he was my alibi
um
and during those four years do you are
you just
surviving or is there like a moment
where you're like okay I have to
strategize like a life within these
walls like I have to figure out a way
where it's not so Grim for me to exist
in here are you just getting through
your day like without much thought so
there was a shift the first two years in
my imprisonment
um I didn't have a verdict yet and so I
felt like I was just kind of like this
lost tourist who was in the in the wrong
place and so I was just waiting to be
allowed to go home and so I spent those
first two years really just feeling like
okay I'm just surviving until the time
when all the adults in the room get
their [__] together two years two years
I was about 20 years old and then the
next two years after I was convicted and
sent his 26 years that's when I had this
sort of like existential crisis come to
like just come into myself like how do I
make my life worth living
and I couldn't figure out how to answer
that question so instead I said how do I
make today worth living and I just kept
asking myself that same question over
and over and over again every day and
what were some like things that made
that day worth living writing a letter
to my mom
um I I like out did myself in in some
things like I would give myself
challenges like I once did 900 sit-ups
in one day you know like so stuff like
that anyway I feel like Esther that
wouldn't be your um yeah I still be like
oh I don't have to work out
I read a lot of books um I helped a lot
of like most of the people that I was in
prison with were illiterate so I helped
a lot of them like write letters to
their family members oh my god
um
I was also I sort of became the
unofficial like translator in prison
because there were a lot of people in um
in there who couldn't speak Italian and
could only sort of kind of speak like a
pigeon English and so I because a lot of
like African immigrants
um or or people who had been used as
like drug mules or something like that
prostitutes that kind of thing
um so they weren't native Italians they
didn't speak the language they didn't
really understand what was going on they
couldn't even read their court documents
much less like explain their ailments to
the doctors or something and so very
often I was called in uh to translate
for people
do you sorry do you just basically wake
up now every day like I can't believe
that I have freedom and like a beautiful
life like do you have that feeling every
day now
definitely what it feels like is that
there I've had many lives like there was
the before prison life that I led then
there was the prison life that I lived
and then there's this life that I'm
living and they they're so different
that it feels like completely different
lives
um
and
um and also because in some really
practical ways they are like when I
first came home from prison I thought I
was gonna get to go back to the life
that I was leading before prison and I
was like oh no the world has incredibly
changed its attitude towards me I'm not
just like some Anonymous kid anymore
um but also I've changed and I have to
like re-figure out who I am and what
what my place is in the world and
um and I have to live with this like
crippling
feeling of how uncertain everything is
in the world like like
the amount of like faith that I had that
like there's some kind of like sense to
the world or that I can trust
authorities or anything like that like
all of that evaporated and so like even
to this day I really struggle with the
idea of like making plans like a lot of
people are like oh yeah what's your like
five year ten year plan and I'm like do
you know how many random ass things are
gonna happen to you that are gonna be
more impactful than any of your [__]
plans do not ask me about my four-year
plan we have to like really relate to
this because
I have a lot of anxiety around planning
in general if someone's like oh like do
you want to go to so and so six months
from now I'm like I you I can't give you
that answer like maybe two weeks out I
can three weeks out I can but I cannot
do a lot of future planning sort of
because like oh in the same way that
like maybe things have happened in my
younger life that have been such like
like life-changing things like
life-shattering things where I'm like I
just I tomorrow I don't know like I
don't know what's around the corner so I
can't give you that answer yeah and and
at the same time like the world sort of
Demands that you do that like I'm having
to you know for career-wise I have to
like make plans for like next year yeah
but at the same time it's like who knows
right so just do the best you can when
you're present in the moment and that's
all you can do like the authority thing
is really scary
um that's so scary to just be like am I
protected am I did you find more like
self-trust through it like definitely
well at first there was a incredible
amount of not self trust because the
police made me feel like I was crazy
um they told me that I had Amnesia and
that I had witnessed the murder and that
I didn't remember it and so I started to
question my own sanity and then
afterwards I blamed myself so much for
like
yeah it's incredibly gas lit so I blamed
myself for years about for what had
happened and I thought it was my fault
that I was going through this whole
experience and God that is so Universal
for a victim to like blame themselves
but then you add that you're [__] in
prison that is crazy and everyone says a
real prison be there and that you're a
bad person and yeah even the people who
like think that maybe you're innocent
think there's something wrong with you
because like the stigma of being someone
who was accused people tend to think
that at the very least you were asking
for it somehow like maybe you're not
guilty of murder but you're guilty of
cartwheels you're guilty of being a
weirdo or whatever it is and so like you
sort of have to grab and like when the
whole world is telling you that you feel
like they must be right and so for years
I blamed myself and it wasn't until I
met other wrongfully convicted people
who had gone through the exact same
experience that I did that I was like oh
[__] people are asking the wrong
question they're constantly asking
what's wrong with me and they're not
asking what's wrong with what was done
to me right right and then do you are do
you have like a network of people that
you still kind of communicate yeah
because I was going to say it's like we
can all try to relate but it's like it's
just such a unique it's such a I'd like
to think that anybody can relate to
anything if they want to like I've had
an incredible relationship with a friend
of mine who
um it's funny she we like connected over
poetry and then after a while she
figured out who I was she didn't know
who I was at first and like she came in
to like hang out and was like oh my God
you're Amanda Knox and I was like [__]
what did you Google and she was like no
no she's like you don't understand
um I was gang raped when I was a
teenager oh my God and everything you
talk about like with that feeling being
you know like how these like overpowered
and vulnerable and made to feel small
and like taken advantage of like all of
that is really resonant with me so like
the feeling like what happens to you
isn't necessarily the thing that
connects people it's the way that it's
impacted you it's the way that it makes
you feel however there are some things
about meeting other wrongfully convicted
people where it's like you just don't
have to explain anything to them right
like the the most relieving thing that
I've ever had happened to me was walking
into a room for the first time of other
wrongfully convicted people by the way
mostly men and mostly men of color
who came up to me and just the first
thing they said was you don't have to
worry about a thing little sister we
know like you don't have to explain a
thing
and I was just like the relief the
relief that washed over me of like oh my
God I don't have to explain myself to
people in this room like
oh
like that I didn't know how much that I
had been holding right um feeling that
and so that makes me emotional I know
like
[__] sorry yo no it's good we can talk
about stupid gross stuff
no but that I'm sure is something that
like so many people can relate to in
different ways of like
wanting to feel understood and for you
to finally after all those years just
have that moment of feeling understood
seems like
really healing oh here we go it's always
we have on our show we have banana
braids
[Music]
I used to feel like I needed to tell
people that happened to me like it felt
like such an important part of like who
I was like I wanted everyone to know
this like thing that I went through and
then
I stopped like personalizing it like I
stopped being like it's like kind of
what you were saying it's like a thing
that happened to me it's not like me or
like a part of me it's just like a thing
that that happened and that's been
really helpful but it's interesting like
where everyone already knew you didn't
really get the experience for people to
not know what happened yeah it wasn't a
choice for me yeah however I think that
it's a there's actually a really
important thing that happens where like
I remember there was a moment where I
was like who am I now like this thing
horrible thing happened to me I just got
home from prison who the [__] am I now
like the only thing that people care
about is the fact that I'm a girl
accused of murder I don't even know what
that means to me like what does that
mean to me and so it takes time for you
to get to the place of being able to say
this isn't just me it's just a thing
that happened to me like I feel like you
have to go through a place of like
having processed it having put it into
context in your own mind and like having
lived some experiences outside of it so
it's not just this thing that's on top
of you that you just like went through
so yeah I mean sometimes it is true that
just you need time to grow up and and
figure out where that thing is and it
put it in its proper place yeah and then
like it kind of feels it feels like very
impactful to not tell it sometimes you
know to not tell the story I'm like oh
that actually feels like really good to
not
hi there and I always have this image of
like every time like I just realized I
was like dragging my teacher had dreads
it was like a Waco dreads just dragging
this like white dreaded guy with me like
throughout my life and just like
dragging by his dreads like come on to
this part of my life I got to tell
everyone about you and then I was like
Let It Go like you know and obviously
it's still a little bit in me but it's
still in me too super still in I don't
think it ever is not in you I work on
that anger though too because the anger
I think you're right it's like it really
does like it separates you from the
outside world
um
yep I also think that
there's something about being a girl
that like that feeling of just not being
believed is different because a perfect
example is like
when we talk about our dramas on this
podcast being sexually assaulted being
you know like all the horrible things
that have happened to us like lately
I've been seeing and reading things like
oh yeah like those girls are lying or
that's it's just it's too much not like
all of those things couldn't have
happened to one person or to kalila
sorry we're not sorry you
have someone like my ex my ex partner
who's like a lovely person but he tells
maybe even more extreme stories about
his life never questioned ever never the
veracity of what he says is never
questioned but mine sexual assault
things that are very believable that
could happen to a woman always just like
that couldn't have happened to her she's
lying are you sure that you were
sexually assigned am I you know what I
mean yes to that doctor's appointment
tell me you weren't bottomless of the
gynecologist I must have asked for it
been on my knees and said do me Dr
mardelli I could also see you doing that
though
on behalf of the the commenters at home
but that must like be also true of your
experience it's like a photo of you
smiling and suddenly you're a hat you're
so happy your roommate is dead like that
yeah this again so this is why it feels
like there was just a story that was
happening on its own with a character on
its own like Foxy knoxy was a character
in other people's narratives and
imaginations that had nothing to do with
me and that I had no agency over I was
not the one writing that script and I
was just the one who was living with the
consequences of it and how do you feel
someone that had a poster of her owner
I do have to ask this question because
like there's always talk on Tick Tock
about how like in Italy like the food
doesn't make you bloated
with the food in prison is that what
people talk about on Tick Tock I don't
know I'm not on TV like like because you
were in prison but in Italy like was the
food you know how like so many people
ask me that question actually like a lot
of people are like oh my God I'm so
sorry we're going to an Italian
restaurant I bet you're tired of that
and I'm like oh you know um I was in
prison attack so no we were not having
caprese
no no I was having prison food I spent
four years in Italy to eat prison food
oh my God
meal prep
like planned out for you wait when you
were in Italy did you feel bloated at
all no because this is like a big
phenomenon on like hot girl Tick Tock
where people talk about like you can eat
pizza and like grains in Italy and you
don't feel bloated because it's not like
poisonous like it is in the U.S well
what is true is that here in the U.S I
never eat pizza here in the US unless
it's made by an actual Italian person
and that's that's due to the way that
they do the dough like the ingredients
like in Italy they treat Pizza like
actual food with like actual ingredients
and they they they don't just like fluff
it up artificially with like weird
plastic cheese like yes yeah no so we
yes Pizza Italy is better okay it is
factually better this might seem like
four years in prison I know that from I
was like it's totally worth it
we didn't eat pizza in prison though I
was from the like the five weeks I was
in Italy before I was putting up oh my
God five weeks was all you were there
yeah
home soon after that no I actually had
just arrived in Italy and I was planning
on spending the year there to study
abroad when you think about Italy as a
whole are you like [__] that place or
are you like okay well that happened
because if that would have happened to
me [__] Pizza [__] anything Italian
related [__] all Italian soccer teams
like just [__] anything relating to that
country like that would be just so my
rage I think would just like bubble over
for this place that this that did this
thing to me I mean
it's not a place that did something to
me it was some people who did something
right to me
um I do think that there was some
aspects of it being in Italy that that
contributed
um one was that I was not fluent in the
language when I was being interrogated
that was a quite a huge Factor
um but other things like
um I think there was because there was
this like Madonna horror dichotomy story
going on that particularly resonated
um in in a culture that sort of was
um that that kind of narrative was more
common to hear wait what what was that
with you just that you were like
sexualized because you were pretty or
like what well so the way that my
prosecution argued the the reason they
said that I'm murdered my roommate
randomly one night
um when I have no History of Violence or
mental illness or even like I have a
good relationship with my roommate the
day before she was murdered we were
texting each other back and forth about
meeting up because it was Halloween like
they're so like we have this good
relationship and they decided to portray
us as she's this stuck up British girl
who doesn't want to be my friend and who
is constantly judging me because I'm
like this [__] American Girl
and so there's the madonna-like Virgin
who ends up getting sucked into my
depraved sex orgy game and then I murder
her in the midst of that game to punish
her for basically like wagging her
British finger at me for being this
[__] American girl that makes perfect
sense it's like
with our show
the conspiracy theories on there oh
Annie didn't look over kalila for three
weeks apparently I had sex with Rick
lastman did you guys know that
apparently that's a
that's something about it like on the
show
apparently that was something that I
kept from the world like I just like
some of these things that are thrown
like I'm like wow men really do have
like this kind of sick imagination
like you know like ooh what's this yeah
what's maybe it's not as like benign as
like you know like it you're like you
just don't read the stuff you know it's
nothing it won't affect your life but
it's like maybe it will and it can and
it has
so oh careful guys
maybe those comments aren't as benign as
we think oh God you're killing us
you're killing us so we saw you last
night at the premiere party for what
yeah what was that like like appearing
on a comedy roast after like I don't
know was that very freeing for you or
yeah yeah it felt good it felt great I
mean Whitney's always been so freaking
supportive and I think that just the
fact that she I mean a lot of people in
my life are like oh man you're you're
like so funny and like so much fun yeah
but like Whitney was like let's
capitalize on that I was like great
let's go
she's she's such a boss and she was like
why do you have to hide like there's
nothing wrong with you being funny like
you made me laugh when we were hanging
out together I like make some people
laugh and I was like [__] yeah
especially if I get to make fun of you
so she's such a good Target
my god there were like farm animals and
and my daughter was having a blast
backstage because they had like these
inflatable like they had these guys who
these poor guys like hours that day just
like in these inflatable animal costumes
for like a five minute thing on the
stage but they were like we're getting
paid we're feeling great so they were
just hanging out backstage like mooing
for Eureka it's so cute
now Whitney's like the perfect amount of
extra her party last night was so cute
and fun yeah you weren't even there when
I put on the only fans thong word you
did that I got there early and Eureka
really wanted to go in the pool and I
had not brought a swimsuit so I was like
well I guess I'm 20 weeks pregnant and
putting on a thong sounds like fun so I
just like I didn't even go into a
dressing room I was just like there by
the pool and I was like well here's my
boobs put them on
yeah there's always
but honestly you could do killing only
fan pregnant with a
yeah
we gotta capitalize me that is true I
was on um ChatterBait
um what is that they're laughing because
these are the only pervs I would know
ChatterBait is basically the site that
has like live girls guys whatever you
want on there and they have
um one of the categories as they do in
PornHub is pregnancy and these women
were incredible like I was part of like
there was this one room that I entered
and there's only seven people in there
so it was very intimate and she was just
squeezing her milk into the camera and I
couldn't have given this woman more
tokens in my life I was like
I was just like milk splashing into the
screen and I just like kept I couldn't
stop for like a whole hour faster would
be into it I'm getting hungry
I was breastfed until I was three and a
half oh do you like do you have memory I
do wow I have those memory memories I
remember
being breastfed I'm very proud of it
yeah like is was that do you feel good
about that do you look at your mom's
boobs in an interesting way no she's
very boob sensitive though like she
doesn't like any stimulation on her
nipples yeah I feel like that can't be
related it's how good her yeah I'm so
scared of you touching my nipples titty
twister like if someone ever did this
with you no I know you wouldn't but I'm
just saying like any twisting to a girl
that's what my mom did to me we're at
JCPenney when we first came I grew up in
the Philippines when I came here when I
was 15. they brought their JC Penny over
and so this was like our big mall outing
the first big American Mall outing and
um my mom was like abusive my whole life
she beat my ass my whole life very
typical I love her now
um but we were JCPenney and she was like
ask for your bra size but I was too
nervous to ask the attendant I was like
no you ask
and she and then she asked my sister you
asked for your bra size she was like no
ma can you ask
dude she took one nipple from my sister
one nipple from me and she just affect
the size of the bra too honestly
my sister and I are first our second
week in America we're walking around
with one blue titty oh
honestly
titty because Todd will be like I'm
gonna pinch her I'm like it's not the
same it's not easy yeah yeah get away
yeah get away listen she's been a prison
and she doesn't want this
she didn't say that
you're not the only one
now okay so you have um Eureka and you
have you have a son on the way I do yeah
so excited you're your perfect little
family I know [__] [__] I know I'm
lucky what can I say it all worked out
and you got to be in a pseudonym so you
got to meet Chris under like
under like just chilled circumstances
and he like spent a good nine months
into our relationship like not Googling
me only like occasionally like I'd bring
up any like he a great example of this
is it's not like I wouldn't bring up
prison because of course it's a big part
of my life
um so he would be like oh let's watch
Wally and I'm like what's Wally and he's
like how do you not know what Wally is
what are you wait and I was like oh I
was in prison
Obama we have a black president
so what did you have access to like what
is like entertained I knew that Obama
I didn't know who Justin Bieber was
though I had no idea wow okay so
confused what about like I feel like
that might have been a blessing were
there any like huge changes in
technology when you came out of prison
like what was like the biggest surprises
of the way life had changed well before
I went to prison it was like flip phones
and you had to go to internet cafes and
then when I got out it was smartphones
and touch screens and internet
everywhere and so like I actually
remember my mom gave me her phone like
in the car chase as we're leaving the
prison she gave me my her phone so I
could call the family and tell them that
I was coming home and I didn't know how
to interact with it because there were
no buttons and so she had to do this
touch screen thing to like show me like
to dial people for me and so I was just
like guy you do it and then I just
talked on the phone and gave it back to
her when I was done when it was time to
go home were you like okay
um like I need to be like mindful of
like how I read integrate because that
has to be so overwhelming even like
stimulus in itself like the sounds of
things again I was super naive and I
thought that I was going to get like I
said I thought I was going to just get
to go back to being a normal person and
I was kind of impatient to go back to
being a normal person because I just
spent four years waiting to be able to
go back to being a normal person so the
last thing I wanted to do was like chill
out and wait
um and my mom wanted me to like live
with her and to go to therapy and do all
these things and I was like I don't want
to do any of that I just want to go back
to school
but of course when I'm going back to
school people are taking pictures of me
in class and another [__] alone
wait so you did go back to school
yep I went back to school I'm not
jealous of that and I got my degree I
finished my degree
um what was the time spent from when you
started college when you finished so I
started college in 2005 and it's not
going to be longer than anything
and I graduated in let's see so it was
2014. okay
mine was eight years
not similar I I went to college early 17
and then
took a while yeah it feels like such a
natural trauma response to like get out
and really want to go back to what you
had before yeah I feel like I would be
homesick and like desperate for what it
was what life was before yeah you're
nostalgic for the life that you had
before you were driving right guys yeah
right like now sort of what is your like
what is your work now like you have your
podcast what's like the main focus of
that or like are you do you work on like
prison reform or I don't even know if
that's the right term but like what is
what do you do now yeah besides being a
mom yeah I'm doing a lot of mom stuff
but besides that my husband and I have
our podcast labyrinths
um which is a thing and we interview
lots of people
um we do also do all production and
scripting and all of that
um but the main idea behind it is we
like to talk to people about when they
felt the most lost and that can come in
many different forms I've talked to
people about miscarriages I've talked to
people about medical issues that they've
had I've talked to people about wrongful
convictions and then on top of that I do
um I try to support the Innocence
Project and the various Affiliated
projects like that I do a lot of
Journalism that has to do with criminal
justice related issues
um especially issues that I feel like
are these very very easy fixes to like
really really big problems an example is
right now in Washington state they're
trying to change the law so that it
makes it illegal for police to lie to
juveniles when they're interrogating
them
because right now it's super super legal
for you to just lie like you're
interrogating people and police are
allowed to lie to you and this is
particularly dangerous when it's
juveniles because they're incredibly
suggestible and so you're getting
juveniles to falsely confess to crimes
that they didn't commit because they've
been lied to by police officers and they
feel like well if the police say I did
it then I either I don't know and I
guess I must have done it or I don't
have like they're never gonna believe me
so I might as well say I did it because
they're the authority figures yeah
they'll like give you a soda there was
like yeah you wanna yeah it's a whole
like Brendan cooler thing and dassi is a
great example so they're trying to
change a lot to at least make it so that
juveniles are not getting lied to even
though they shouldn't be lying dude
Brendan dassey he was told if you just
say this you get to go home and watch
WrestleMania and the kid was like oh I
just want to go home and watch
WrestleMania I'll just I'll tell you
like at a certain point in interrogation
I'll tell you from my experience like
you were willing to believe and say
anything as long as they stop yelling at
you [__] so it's like because you they
get you to the point of like they
isolate you they Gaslight you they lie
to you I was hit and like
you feel crazy yeah they were hitting me
in the back of the head telling me to
remember they were hitting me and saying
remember remember my God
I'm never eating pizza again
no pizza is great I never got to eat
pizza as much so like I eat all the
pizza I can now well if we have a pizza
party I'll remember that
I'll smack her in the back remember you
said this
is such an amazing chat you are so open
and you also seem like so intelligent
and like I would guess that before all
this happened you must have already been
like mature and like in touch because I
don't know I just feel like
you know you come out of this situation
it like you might start doing porn or
like there's probably well she went to
Whitney's house she could very easily
start you never know I was in that only
only bomb it was very almost there to
video David
um and I hope everyone watches you crush
alongside Annie on the official Whitney
cup Rush that was so fun which is free
on only fans TV
um yeah and everyone should check out
your podcast I'm excited is it Labyrinth
labyrinths labyrinths yeah yeah very
exciting and congratulations on the new
baby thank you yeah it's very exciting
to see you yeah I'm so excited I finally
got to get on your guys oh yeah for
having me it was a quirky time it was a
quirky time thanks guys
thank you
[Music]